-One, two, three.
Flip!
What?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Boom!
♪♪
-We're about to have
a Water War.
We're going to play
the card game War
but if you lose a hand, you get
a pint of water in the face.
We each have
five glasses of water.
The first one to throw
all five glasses
on their opponent wins
and gets to water-cannon
the loser.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Lots of ways to get wet,
only one way to win.
-There's lots of water here.
That's a pint.
-Yes!
[ Laughter ]
-You ready to do this?
-So ready.
[ Laughter ]
I was born ready.
-So we just turn on three.
One, two, three.
Ohh.
So nice to see you, buddy.
-Snap.
-So good to see you, man.
I love what you've done
with your hair.
Kind of missed
on that a little bit.
The hair's throwing me off.
I missed a little bit on that.
Alright, good, here we go.
-Yeah, it's hard to see
with the bangs.
Those bangs were a commitment.
-I'm keeping mine --
I'm keeping mine dry.
Here we go.
-Alright, ready?
-One, two, three.
-Boom!
[ Cheering ]
-It seems so disrespectful,
doesn't it?
-It really does. It really does.
Everything that you believe in.
-I've never done it,
especially --
-You don't have to.
-Honestly, what would be
really fun --
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Okay, it is satisfying,
I admit that.
-Alright, you ready?
-Yes.
-You trust that no one dealt
with the different decks
or anything,
the cards are all the same?
-Not -- not at all,
but let's just keep going.
-Sure, here we go.
One, two, three.
-See, that close is suspicious.
-I got a little tickle.
I got a little tickle
in my throat.
[ Cheering ]
That one got
the microphone there.
That one got the mic.
That one got the mic, there.
-That got in my nose.
-Up your nose.
Up your nose. Here we go.
-Take your shirt off!
-No, I can't, I can't!
I have a show to do.
I can't take my shirt off.
Sorry, I apologize. I apologize.
-When anyone asks you that,
just say, "After you."
-I like that.
That's the answer.
-No, no, no, no.
-No, sir. No, sir, not you.
You ready?
One, two, three.
-Boom!
Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was velocity.
I went for velocity.
-I-I inhaled on that throw.
-It's highly chlorinated.
-Alright, here we go.
This is a tight game.
One, two, three.
-Oh, Jesus.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're not going anywhere
in that, right?
[ Laughs ]
It's cold,
it's cold water, too, man.
-It's -- it's oddly warm.
-That one was, I apologize.
Yeah.
-My bench is sinking inward.
It's like a puddle in here.
One, two, three, war.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
-That's war.
Alright,
now we bring these out.
Go under your bottom shelf here.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-Oh, yeah, that's there.
Whoever wins
this gets the pitcher.
Here we go. This is war.
So you go three cards down.
So, one-- Just put them down,
put them down. One, two.
-One, two.
-Three.
-There's like gel
and [bleep]
War!
[ Cheering ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ahh! Yah! Whoa! Whoa!
♪♪
I feel like I'm in an Irish --
Irish pub.
-We're down to --
-You're definitely
"Baywatch" now.
You just rode the wave, bro.
-You gotta see me
in "Point Break," Forrest.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's my line.
-Oh, man, my toupee came off.
Ready?
-Yep. One, two, three.
-Phew!
-[Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
-One, two, three.
-That's it! I won! I won War!
Sorry, buddy.
[ Bell dings ]
-You get to spray me now?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Guys, Zac Efron.
-Jason, since you play Aquaman,
I wanted to challenge you
to a Water War.
We'll play the card game War,
but if you lose the hand,
you get a --
[ Laughter ]
You get a pint of water
in the face, okay?
We have five glasses of water.
The first one to throw all five
glasses on their opponent wins
and gets to water-cannon
the loser.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Lots of ways to get wet,
but only one way to win.
[ Laughter ]
-You love saying that.
-I know, I know.
-There's only one way to win!
-Alright.
Are you ready for this?
-I'm ready.
-Do you trust the cards?
Do you want to shuffle?
Are you all good?
Do you trust me?
-I trust you.
[ Laughter ]
-One, two --
-Oh, hold on, hold on.
Hold on, hold on, hang on,
hang on, hang on.
Let's just do it.
Ready?
-One, two, three, flip.
-Ah!
-I won.
[ Laughter ]
Now I'm not sure
if I wanted to win.
Do you want to win?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wore my hat, Jimmy.
-Alright, alright.
Roots, I'm going to run out
of here if things get nasty.
One, two, three, play.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Dude, it's great having
you on the show.
[ Laughter ]
I love "Frontier,"
it's fantastic.
I like the beginning --
I also like the end is great.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
One, two, three, flip.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
-I think this is like
Aquaman loves water?
-I don't know what's going on.
It's not rigged.
I'm so sorry to do this to you.
-It better not be rigged, Jimmy.
-I swear.
I swear, it's not, right?
If it was, I had nothing
to do with it.
There is a writer that's
running around the hall --
-Throw it in my face!
-Alright, yeah, yes, sir!
-Now!
-Yes, sir!
-Again!
-Yes, okay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
One, two, three, flip.
-Okay.
I'm good with this.
-Sorry, sorry, sorry.
[ Applause ]
Come on!
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to get
your suit wet.
-Yeah.
Well, okay.
Just a little sticky down there.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
One, two, three.
Oh, yeah.
-That was like --
I mean, that was like --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Go ahead, go ahead.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Here we go!
-Oh, that one won that one.
-Oh, trust me, I know
what it feels like.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, trust me.
-There it is.
-For the win!
One, two, three, come on.
Oh.
-Aah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
There we go.
-Is there more water
in your glass?
[ Laughter ]
I got basically slapped
in the face
with water just there.
-It's a talent.
You gonna kick my ass?
Oh [ Bleep ].
[ Cheers ]
Oh!
It's the last one, man.
[ Cheers ]
-One, two, three!
Flip! What?!
-Boom! Boom!
[ Band plays ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That went up --
That one went up my nose.
That one went up
my nose right there.
Alright. Here we go.
-Alright.
-One, two, three.
I hate you!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Boom!
Bam!
There we are, baby!
[ Laughter ]
Here we are.
Hey, this is amazing.
-This is for the win.
I love you, buddy.
-I love you, too.
Let's do this.
-One, two, three!
Oh!
No, you know what that means?
-This is amazing!
That means take out
your pitcher.
You got a pitcher down there.
Now, pick three,
and when we flip over that,
that is the
all-time winner.
Pitcher, glass, water cannon.
-One, two, three, right?
-The fourth card.
-Ready?
-One card, two card, three,
and then flip this one.
-Oh, Jimmy.
-This is war, baby!
-No matter what happens,
I love you.
-I love you too, man.
-Bam!
Oh, my God!
Double [ Bleep ] War!
[ Laughter and cheers ]
Has there ever been
a double war?
-There's never been
a double war!
-You can't do that.
-Yes!
-Alright.
-Now what happens?
-We have to do it again.
One, two, three.
-Alright, okay.
-One, two -- three --
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Drum roll ]
[ Cheers ]
Whoo, hoo, hoo, hoo!
-The winner! Jason Momoa.
[ Cheers and applause ]